so for me as an entrepreneur what are
the type of design types that I need to
care about so I'm my specialty is
interaction design so as you probably
guess from me saying tasks tasks tasks
over and over again your last few
minutes that's where I biased words so
can we focus on trying to understand
users and behaviors think about the
types of things they want to do and how
to best fulfill them that's just one of
the specializations there's many other
very common ones are visual design right
they focus on everything that the user
sees while they're engaging with your
experience is their luck colors and
stuff like that or it colors is one but
it's also things like layout like scale
any iconography that's there you know
everything from bouncing upward anything
that becomes a pixel in that piece of
software right digital design tries to
concentrate on that and there's
thousands of small decisions that go
into that that is their specialization
then there's also things like motion
design this is a newer you know focus
for design in many cases and they're
concerned with how anything animates you
know big or small to give the user a
sense that their feedback is being heard
and that the system is responding to it
and just kind of bring the product to
life a little bit and make it feel like
it's something that they're they're
really kind of engaging in this push and
pull with you can also stress things
with emotive animation right oh
absolutely
you know animation is a great way to
tell the user where they where their
attention should be focused at any given
time and then there's other
specializations there's things like
Industrial Design you know the design of
physical objects there's sound design
there's gonna brand or you know print
design and so on and so on and so on you
know anything that you're doing on this
product that has some decision that
needs to be made there's probably a
whole discipline of design that can help
you make that decision so what you're
basically telling me is that I need to
hire eight people yes wait no no you can
get by with fewer okay so I know most
small teams just don't have that
capacity to hire all the specializations
um so the good news is that
in my experience most designers are
hybrids you know they might identify as
being one of those specializations but
they often have you know familiarity to
varying degrees with the other fields of
the discipline so what's important to
keep in mind when you hire is kind of
have a sense of what your expectations
are going to be like what are you going
to need out of this designer do you need
interaction and visual do they need to
work on your brand for you and make sure
that the capabilities are in the people
that you hire or make sure that they're
comfortable directing the work of
contractors who might be able to kind of
augment the capabilities that they lack
how do they know if they're any good wow
that's a good question I think the best
way to judge a designer is from their
work and so you should certainly ask for
work samples you should look for the
portfolio you should find out what kind
of things get them excited about design
are they like very focused on the user
and on simplicity are they a designer
who can come in and kind of give more
pizazz a little sex appeal a little
gloss to the product and there's appeal
to kind of having all of those types of
people involved with the work